اصبح مانشستر يونايتد موطنه الجديد وهي
لحظه جوهريه في حياه رونالدو فرصه لاثبات
نفسه في المسرح العالمي من خلال اللعب مع
نادي عريق كهذا وعقبا انضمامه الى النادي
منح رونالدو قميصا رقم 7 وهو الرقم الذي
ارتداه نجوم يونايتد الايقونات مثل ديفيد
بيكهام وجورج بيست
كان الضغط هائلا وكانت التوقعات المعلقه
على ابن الثامنه عشره كبيره علينا ان
نتذكر انه ابان وصوله الى مانشستر يونايتد
ترافورد
منذ وقت قصير لينضم الى ريال مدريد وكان
بيكم النجم اللامعه وسط النجوم اذا كانت
كوكبه مانشستر يونايتد تفتقد احدا نجومها
اكبر كوكب فيها ان صح التعبير نحن نعرف
الان بالطبع ان رونالدو اتى لاحقا وطغى
حتى على انجازات
اما حينها فقد اتى كمراهق النحيل البدن
اغلى مراهق على الاطلاق في كره القدم
الانجليزيه كان ثمن صفقته مليون جنيه
استرليني ونصف المليوني تقريبا وماذا فعل
رونالدو ارتدا قميصه رقم 7 وهذا يخبرنا
الكثير عن طبيعه رونالدو ففي تلك السن كان
مستعدا لارتداء القميص رقم سبعه الذي لم
يرتده بيكم فقط بل ايرك كانت تونه ايضا
انه القميص الايقوني في ملعب اولد ترافورد
وكانت الخطوه الاولى التي اقدم عليها
رونالدو هي قبول ذلك الرقم وهذا يتطلب
الكثير من الثقه بالنفس في السادسه عشر من
اغسطس عام 2003 لعب رونالدو مباراته
الاولى مع فريق مانشستر يونايتد على ارضه
ضد فريق بولتون وفي الدقيقه الستين دخل
المباراه على تصفيق مع الوقوف حيث استبدل
نيكيبات طوال الجزء التالي من المباراه
هتف المشجعون باسم رونالدو فقد بث طاقه
جديده في الفريق اعتقد ان خطه يونايتد
فيما يتعلق برونالدو كانت على الارجح ان
يحاولوا تقديمه الى الدوري الانجليزي
بالتدريج فهذا بلد جديد وكان يتعلم لغه
جديده ببراعه كبيره واعتقد ان خطه كانت ان
يحاولوا التعامل معه بطريقه نفسها التي
اتبعوها مع وهي الاستعانه به بتحفظ لكن لا
يمكن فعل ذلك مع رونالدو قال جورج بيست ان
مباراه رونالدو الاولى مع مانشستر كانت
واحده من اكثر المباريات حماسه مما شاهده
في حياته فعندما يقول جورج هذا عن لاعب
صاعد سينتبه اليه الجميع حكما انتهت
المباراه بفوز مانشستر يونايتد باربعه
اهداف نظيفه ومع ان رونالدو لم يسجل هدفا
الا انه ساعد في تقديم الكره نحو المرمى
مرات عده بفضل سرعته ومهارته العاليه في
المناوره وقدم تمريره حاسمه في احراز هدف
يونايتد الثاني في ذلك الوقت كانت قدرات
رونالدو الاستثنائيه قد بدات تبرز بوضوح
ولياقته البدنيه بالطبع التي عمل على
تطويرها طوال مسيرته يتمتع بقوه هائله
وقدمين سريعتين الى حد لا يصدق قدماه
كيديه ساحر قدرته على تغيير سرعته مذهله
وسرعته القصوى لا تصدق كان قد بدا حينها
يطغى على انجازات على الجناح الايسر مع
مانشستر يونايتد فبات كريستيانو رونا يقدم
ذلك واكثر على الجناح الايمن مجموعه
مهاراته لا تصدق واصبح يحرج فعلا بعض افضل
المدافعين في الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
اسبوعا بعد اسبوع بفضل مناوراته ومهاراته
وسرعته وقوته التي لم يروا مثيلها ولم
يختبروها ابدا من قبل ولم يستطيعوا
مجاراتها بسرعه كبيره اصبح رونالدو واحدا
من افضل اللاعبين في الدوري الجديد في
الموسم الاول لرونالدو مع مانشستر يونايتد
تصدر اسمه العناوين على الرغم من حقيقه
انه كان يلعب 50% من المباريات فقط لكن
بعد ثلاثه اشهر فقط مع الفريق الاول سجل
رونالدو هدفه الاول ضد بورتسماز سدد هذا
الهدف من خلال ركله حره مذهله تخطط حارس
المرمى بسرعه كبيره واستقرت في الزاويه
اليمنى العلويه للمرمى لم يثبت رونالدو
انه لاعب عظيم من كل النواحي فحسب بل
استعرض ايضا دقته الكبيره في تسديد
الركلات الحره
[تصفيق]
فورد يهدف لصاحب الرقم 7 الجديد انهى
رونالدو موسمه الاول في الدوري الانجليزي
الممتاز كفائزا بكاس الاتحاد الانجليزي
بالتغلب على فريق ميلول في المباراه
النهائيه ساعد رونالدو في تسديد الهدف
الافتتاحي الذي الهم الفريق نحو الفوز كان
في الثامنه عشره لاعبا اساسيا في يونايتد
كما فاز بالجائزه الاولى في انجلترا
[موسيقى]
في مطلع عام 2005 قدم رونالدو بعضا من
افضل مبارياته مع يونايتد على الاطلاق في
مباراههم ضد استون فيلا سدد رونالدو هدفا
وتمريره حاسمه غيارات طاقه الفريق جذريا
وساعده في الفوز بثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدف
واحد على ارضه المباراه الثانيه البارزه
له كانت ضد اكبر منافسا ليونايتد انذاك
وهو فريق وارسنال بث رونالدو في هذه
المباراه ايضا طاقه جديده في الفريق واحرز
هدفين مساعدا يونايتد في الفوز على منافسه
الاكبر باربعه اهداف مقابل هدفين على ارض
الخصم كان رونالدو قد بدا يصبح اللاعب
المفضل لدى الجماهير في مانشستر واكثر
لاعب معروف في كره القدم الانجليزيه لكن
مع اقتراب كاس العالم 2006 تحول من محبوب
الجماهير الى شرير في مباراه واحده
مع بدء كاس العالم للعام 2006 كان
كريستيانو رونالدو بالطبع قد اصبح معروفا
في ارجاء انجلترا واوروبا ايضا كواحدا من
اعظم اللاعبين في العالم وكانت هناك حاله
الترقب هائله لما سيقدمه في كاس العالم
وكان هناك بالطبع صراع محتدم بين انجلترا
والبرتغال في ربع النهائي رونالدو ضد روني
زميله في مانشستر يونايتد وتصدمت القارتان
في شكل حتمي ولا ينسى بالتاكيد